CLAY BAVOR: Good morning.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning, everyone.
It's great to see so
many people fired up
about VR here at 9:00 AM.
Thanks for being here, yeah.
I'm Clay Bavor, I lead
the VR team at Google.
I'm also pretty
fired up about VR.
Pro tip for the
people in the back,
I saw some pretty intense
tans, sunburns yesterday.
The sun comes in
this way, so people
on the border right
there, you might
want to come down unless
you want a great tan.
So hopefully caught the keynote
yesterday about Daydream,
and that's what today is about.
We're going to go a lot deeper
on all of the components of it.
But before we do that, I wanted
to talk just briefly about VR
and why it's important to us.
And if I can just do a quick
poll, how many people have been
in a VR system where you've
had that moment of like,
oh my god I'm there,
I'm somewhere else.
I love this.
This is like the highest
ratio of any talk I've given,
so that's great.
So you know what
this is about, you
know what I'm talking about.
Now for people who haven't,
for folks on the Livestream,
there's no substitute
for actually
being in one of these demo
rooms, in one of these systems.
But I want to walk you
through an experience
that we share with
a lot of people
who are seeing VR for the
first time in one of our labs.
And it starts here,
poolside And it's
kind of this abstract
pool, there's
like a white grid
for the ground.
And you look around, and
you look to your right,
and there is a diving board.
And then you look up and
there's another diving board.
And you know where
this is going.
So that diving board is 150
feet tall, 50 meters or so.
And we teleport you up
there, and what happens
next is pretty interesting.
People immediately lower
their center of gravity,
they crouch down.
Some reach for a hand railing
that's not actually there.
And we ask people
to walk to the edge,
and look over, and step off.
And it looks really
scary even from here.
I'm imagining from
there it looks scarier.
And most people can't step
off, they can't do it.
Even I have a hard time,
knowing that I'm just in, like,
a room in Mountain View.
And so what's happening here?
Now for those of you
who are deep into VR,
you know what this is
about, it's presence.
And presence is the VR
jargon for that feeling
that you're really
somewhere else.
And it happens when all
of your different senses--
sight, sound, how
you're moving your body,
proprioception, your vestibular
system, all line up and agree.
And your brain just
says, yep, I'm there.
And it's how VR can make you
feel like you're experiencing
something directly.
And that's pretty
important to us at Google.
That's because we've always
cared about information,
organizing it, making it
useful and accessible.
But people think of information
as, like, numbers and words,
sentences, and so on.
But experience, in many
cases, is the most direct form
of information.
And if you think
about it, there's
a world of difference
between reading some words
and sentences, a
book about Paris,
and then actually
visiting Paris,
and walking the
streets yourself,
and actually being there.
And so we think that
VR has the potential
to connect people with
this kind of information,
experiential information,
in a pretty profound way.
We just think VR is amazing.
We want to bring it to the
world and make it for everyone.
And our next step
in that is Daydream,
and we talked about
Daydream yesterday.
If you didn't catch
the session yesterday,
I just wanted to roll a quick
video which we shared yesterday
really highlighting most of
all the Daydream controller,
but it'll give you a flavor for
how this all comes together.
Can we roll the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
For some reason
yesterday, people
were especially excited about
flipping pancakes in VR.
So yeah, that's one
of the things you'll
be able to do in Daydream.
So daydream has
three parts to it.
And we're going to go into
a number of these today
in a lot more detail.
First, our VR
optimized smartphones,
what we call Daydream
ready smartphones that
have very high
specifications, and displays,
and sensors, and the
SOC, the processor in it.
And also VR optimizations, which
we've made as part of Android N
at really all
levels of the stack.
The second part is
a reference design
for headsets and controllers,
a really comfortable VR
viewer, and a powerful
but expressive controller.
And then finally, apps,
including Google Play,
to make it really easy for
users to discover, buy, find,
and install VR apps.
So to get us started going
one level deeper on this,
I'd like to turn it
over to Nathan Martz who
leads our developer products.
Nathan.
NATHAN MARTZ: Thanks, Clay.
I have to say it is so
exciting to be here today.
You know, one of my
earliest memories
was the night my dad came
home with our first computer.
It was an Atari 800
XL-- yeah, there you go.
48 kilobytes bytes
of RAM, support
for upper and lowercase
characters, pretty awesome.
But the thing I
loved most about it
was the fact that when
you put in the cartridge
and turned it on, this entire
world sprang into existence
inside the computer.
And for five-year-old Nathan,
that was as good as it got.
It's amazing that today we have
technology that's so advanced,
that's so powerful,
it doesn't just
have great graphics or
realistic sound effects,
it can actually make you
feel like you're physically
present in another world.
That is phenomenal.
And the fact that you can
do all of this on a computer
small enough that it fits in
your pocket is just incredible.
We live in amazing times.
But of course, creating presence
on a smartphone is easier
said than done.
Of course, just hitting
the 20 millisecond motion
to photon latency bar,
getting below that,
which is the gold standard
of VR, doing that on a phone
is hard.
But we have a more
fundamental problem, I think,
which is that we're all taking
devices that run on batteries
and trying to create experiences
for them that feel just as
compelling as
experiences for computers
that plug into your front
neighborhood power plant.
And closing that gap is
fundamentally difficult.
So the way we solved
that with Daydream
is through hardware and
software designed in concert
with one another.
We've tried to make sure that
every facet of the platform
supports every other.
Today I'm going to walk
you through the hardware
and software that
makes that possible.
And the developer
tools that we're
going to be providing
that help you
take advantage of all of it.
Of course for us, the
foundation of Daydream
is the phone itself.
And great VR experiences
require great hardware.
You have to have all
of the right parts
to ensure a high quality,
low latency experience.
So we've ensured that
every Daydream phone has
a low persistence
display to make
sure there's no ghosting
or unnecessary lag coming
from the display itself.
We have a high quality SOC
which will let all of you
create amazing experiences
and render them at 60 frames
a second.
And of course, the sensors in
the phone are super critical.
We've made sure that they're all
high performance, high quality,
low latency sensors
so that there's
a direct connection between
what you do in the real world
and what you see in
the virtual world.
Now it's not actually a
single phone for Daydream,
it's a standard for phones
called Daydream ready.
And the great thing
about the standard
is that for developers, it
gives you a platform that you
can feel confident about.
You know that if you're building
for the Daydream ready spec,
any Daydream phone
will run your app well.
And it gives
consumers confidence
that when they buy
a Daydream app,
it'll run well on
any phone they have
as long as it's Daydream ready.
Now of course, great
hardware doesn't just
give you a sense of presence,
it requires great software
as well.
Which is why we've work very
closely with the Android team
on Android N and its VR mode.
We've worked to make
sure that Android is just
as good as a great OS for VR.
And there's a few key
components that we've
made available to developers.
The first of those is a low
latency support for Android N.
And that's the foundation
for VR and for presence.
We have a sustained performance
mode which manages the hardware
and makes sure that when
users decide to get in VR
they can stay in VR
as long as they want.
We have high quality
head tracking algorithms
that fuse all of the data
from the sensors in the phone
and track your head movement.
So that looking around
in the virtual world
is just as natural as
it is in the real world.
But for all of this, we know
that your phone is still
fundamentally your phone.
And you're going to
get calls, and you're
going to get text messages.
So we've made sure to port key
components of the Android UI
into VR.
So that if you get a call
or get a text message,
we render it for you
in stereo, and you
can decide whether
you want to stay in VR
or leave to act on
that notification.
Now if you take a Daydream
phone running Android N,
and you combine
it with a viewer,
you get an incredible
sense of presence.
You feel like you're
somewhere else.
But to a certain extent, all
you can do is look around.
I spent much of my career
as a game developer,
and I developed a deep respect
for the power of interactivity.
You know, when you think about
the things we learn really
early in life, in
infancy, the first thing
we learn is how to look around.
And then we learn
how to use our hands.
We learn how to reach
out and touch the world.
We learn about our heads
and our hands together.
In Daydream, we
saw an opportunity
to provide access to both
heads and hands in VR.
We did that through the creation
of the Daydream controller.
This controller is
simple enough that anyone
can use it even
while they're in VR
and can't actually
see their hands.
But we've also made
it expressive enough
that developers can
use it to create
rich, amazing interactions.
It's precise enough that you
can use it as a laser pointer,
but it's also responsive
enough to swing it
like a tennis racket.
We've added a
clickable touch pad
so you can both grab and
interact with virtual objects
as well as effortlessly
browse a media collection.
There's an App button, which is
totally under the developers'
control, and a
Home button, which
we reserve for critical
user interactions
like returning to the
Daydream home screen.
Now we know that for developers,
you need a stable platform.
You need input you can rely on.
So we've designed the
viewer and the phone
to go together literally,
and will require every user
to have the Daydream
controller when they enter VR.
That way when someone
launches your Daydream app,
you know exactly what controller
they have in their hand.
And we believe that
this combination
of Daydream ready phones
with Daydream viewers
and the controller
will let developers
create incredible, rich,
immersive VR experiences.
But that's not just a theory.
We've been working
with some of the best
developers in the world
to make that a reality.
I'd like to welcome a
studio to the stage who
is known for continually
pushing the balance of what's
possible in real time graphics.
One of the most innovative
developers in the world
the creators of the
amazing Unreal Engine.
We've been working with them
very closely on Daydream.
To tell you more about
that partnership,
I'd like to introduce
their CTO, Kim Libreri.
KIM LIBRERI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Nathan, and hello,
Google I/O. And Epic,
our mission is to
give developers
the very best tools for
building immersive and visually
impressive experiences
with fantastic performance
on all the platforms
that we support.
We've been creating
VR experiences now
for many years that not
only push visual fidelity,
but also what's possible in
terms of input, interaction,
characters, and
gameplay mechanics.
Every project that we work
on extends the capabilities
of Unreal Engine, and
we give these back
to developers on a daily
basis through GitHub.
Today we're very,
very proud to be
part of a new chapter
in VR history,
and we've been eagerly preparing
for the arrival of Daydream,
and we're ready to give
you a look at a project
that we've been working
on that helps realize
the potential of this
awesome new platform
and what developers can do
with it on Unreal Engine 4.
Check out the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-For years we made video
games where you would
sit on other side of the glass.
Now you're inside
the real 3D world
with a real feeling of presence.
-Daydream's an exciting
new mobile VR platform,
and what it does is take
some of the high VR features
that we've seen in
desktop VR applications
and brings them to Android
so that we can really
up the level of fidelity in
our mobile VR experiences.
-What's especially
exciting about Daydream
is that you have complete
freedom of movement.
You don't have a
cord tangling you up.
You also have this
amazing controller
that lets you interact,
it lets you throw things,
it lets you choose
where you want to move.
-So when people think
about mobile VR,
you generally think
of look aiming,
are your hands
locked to your head?
But with a Daydream controller,
it's a whole new ball game.
You can actually freely
interact with the world
in a natural way, and
that feels really good.
-The Daydream
integration with Unreal,
it works out of the box with
all the interfaces for VR
that you're already
familiar with.
So there's nothing new to
learn, you can jump in there
and start creating experiences
with the tools from UE4.
-At Epic, we're really
excited about Daydream
because, well,
everyone has a phone.
This really takes
VR to the masses.
It gives you the ability to
have the same kind of experience
you would have on really
high end VR systems,
but now completely immersive and
with this beautiful controller.
And we know that
Unreal Engine 4 is
going to power some absolutely
amazing and incredible
experiences there.
-This is a sample project
I made using assets
from the marketplace.
I'm really excited to see
what you guys do with Daydream
and Unreal Engine 4.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
KIM LIBRERI: Thank you.
Pretty amazing.
Mobile VR is going to look
that good, it's amazing.
This is barely
scratching the surface
of what's going to be possible.
The Daydream controller
is a major advancement
in terms of how you can
craft gameplay mechanics,
explore a virtual world,
all on your mobile device.
Natural input that's
made for VR is
hugely important
in terms of making
you believe that you've been
transported to another place.
And what's better is that if
you incorporate motion controls,
you really, really feel a
high level of immersion.
Daydream empowers you
to create rich, deeply
interactive content for mobile.
And we can't wait to see the
awesome content and games,
demos, and all the
amazing things that
are going to follow using
Daydream and Unreal Engine 4.
Thanks very much.
Back to Nathan.
NATHAN MARTZ: Thanks, Kim.
Thanks so much.
So that's so cool to see
what people are already
making for Daydream.
But I'm sure many of you
are wondering, when can I
be a Daydream developer?
And I'm really proud to say
that you can do that right now.
For those of you who
are C++ developers--
and we know that many of our
core VR developers love C++--
we've just launched an NDK for
Daydream that gives you direct
low level access to all of
the features of our hardware
and software platform.
And we know that
many of you actually
like to use game engines
like Unity and Unreal,
and we've got you
covered, as well.
If you're a Unity
developer, we're
really proud to say that there's
a plugin available today,
and we'll have a native
integration coming out
this summer.
If you're an Unreal
developer, you
can start today, right
now, using the preview
version of Unreal 4.12.
For all of this information
about how you can be a Daydream
developer, including how
to build your own Daydream
Developer Kit, check out
developers.google.com/vr.
And I'm going to hand it
over to Lindsay Metcalf, one
of our team's lead
designers to show you
the Daydream experiences
and what they'll
look like for our
users, and how we're
going to help them discover the
incredible experiences that all
of you will create.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDSAY METCALF: Thanks, Nathan.
We've learned so much
about designing good VR,
and we're looking forward to
sharing it with you all at I/O
this week.
So I'm going to walk you
through Daydream Home
and take a look at how we've
designed the experience
to really connect people to
the very best VR content.
Then I'm going to take you
through a couple of the apps
that we've designed and
share some of the things
that we've learned
that will help you
create your very own VR apps.
This is Daydream Home.
It comes with every
Daydream ready phone,
and it's the first
thing that people
will see when they enter
their Daydream VR experience.
And for VR, crafting
the right environment
is so important for
facilitating presence.
So for Daydream Home,
we really wanted
to create a welcoming space that
had a bit of wonder and delight
inside of it, and
it was somewhere
that you'd want to stop
and hang out for a bit
before you embarked on
your next experience.
Daydream Home is also
your experience launcher.
This is where you can see and
launch your favorite apps,
access Play Store
to get new content,
and also access system settings.
But Daydream Home isn't
just a list of apps.
So up here on the top row,
these are discovery windows.
And discovery windows
are where we're
going to promote and curate
the very best content
that you create.
Discovery windows we've
designed with a sense
of depth and parallax.
So you can really get a sense
of peeking into a new 3D world.
You can step up to
a discovery window,
and peer in, and really get
a sense for the world that
will teleport you to.
And using Android
deep links, you
can add intent filters to
these discovery windows,
and they will take users
to directly the content
inside of your apps.
And the importance
of this is it means
that if you add a new episode
or a level to your game,
it means that you can
promote it, or them,
and you don't actually
have to have a new app.
The users can already have the
app installed on their phone.
Next let's take a look
at Play Store in VR.
Play Store will connect
people to all of your apps.
And since this is
Play Store, it means
we're starting with a large
developer community, all of you
out here.
And it also means that
we have a global payments
and distribution
infrastructure that
will support things like
in-app purchases from day one.
We designed Store to
make it easy to browse
for apps and games in VR
by showcasing collections
of curated content,
as well as making
it easy to navigate by
swiping through the content
with the Daydream controller.
Now I'm going to dive into
the Google Street View
app in Play Store VR and
take a more detailed look.
Here we've added
VR-specific features
to help you promote
your apps, such as 360
photosphere previews that you
can preview all around you
instead of just flat,
static screenshots.
And in VR, even with
the most exciting games,
it's really important to
make sure we're designing
comfortable experiences.
So we've added a
motion intensity rating
to help people find content
that's right for them.
And let's be realistic here.
No matter how
awesome VR is, we're
still going to spend most of
our time in the real world.
So for the times that you're
away from your Daydream viewer,
or Daydream mobile app
will make it really easy
to discover and queue up
content to try out later.
So when you're on the go and
you have some time to browse,
but you don't have
your viewer on hand,
you can queue up VR
videos to watch later.
Or if you're at a
friend's house and you
hear about an
incredible new VR game,
you can download the app right
there from your mobile phone
and the game will be there
waiting for you next time you
return to Daydream Home.
Yesterday we mentioned that a
VR version of YouTube is coming,
so now let's take a look.
With stereoscopic VR
video, 360 livestreaming,
and spacial audio, we've built
an awesome foundation for truly
immersive video with YouTube.
You can step inside a video
and have it all around you,
and you can really
feel like you're there.
Including hanging out with great
white sharks, which in VR, is
actually pretty scary.
YouTube is also a huge
part of discovery for VR.
I think many of
us and many people
have had their first
experience with virtual reality
here in YouTube.
So we've been working with
our friends at YouTube
to bring this all together
in a standalone VR app.
I'm sharing this
with you because we
think YouTube is going to be
one of the best ways for you
to reach users and
show off your apps.
A lot of us are already
using YouTube to share
development tips and tricks.
Now with the VR video creation
tools that the YouTube team is
hard at work on, it will also
be an incredible way for you
to connect with your audience
and build a community.
So you'll be able to upload
360 video, trailers, gameplay,
basically everything
that you'd want
to get people really excited
about the content you're
going to create.
So we've designed the
Daydream experience
around helping people
connect to your content
and continue to reengage
with it over time.
But more than anything, what
we're really excited about
is seeing what you are
all going to create.
And we know that
there are thousands
of undiscovered things
left to explore in VR.
So to help, whatever we learn,
from performance optimisations
to user experience, we want
to share that with you.
So today we're excited to
introduce Daydream Labs.
Daydeam Labs is where we're
going to experiment and share
what we learned with the world.
We're hard at work right
here in Mountain View,
and we're exploring
everything from usability,
to hardware, to new
user experiences
for virtual reality.
And as part of
this effort, we're
rapid prototyping to explore
what makes VR useful, fun,
and also sometimes bad.
So so far, we've been building
about two app experiments
a week for a while.
And today we're going
to start sharing
these lessons with everyone.
First we're going to
start by giving you
access to our Daydream
design playground
to get you started developing
for the Daydream controller.
We'll give you access to all the
different types of experiences
that we've created so far,
and from flipping pancakes
to playing tennis, we have
about 15 different ways
to interact with the controller
that we've thought of so far.
We're also giving another
talk this morning on lessons
learned from Daydream Labs.
This is focused on our rapid
prototyping initiative,
and we're going to start
sharing all of this
regularly on the Google VR blog.
We're so excited to
join the conversation,
and we can't wait to see
what everyone builds.
I'd now like to hand
this back to Clay.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAY BAVOR: One
of the prototypes
we get to see as part of the
session Lindsay mentioned
is a VR watering can.
We took a Vive
controller and jammed it
in the front of a watering can.
And turns out, it's very
natural to water things in VR
when you have a watering can.
So anyway, stay tuned for that.
Maybe even better
than the pancakes.
So hopefully this
all gives you an idea
of how some of the
parts of Daydream
come together, from the Daydream
ready smartphones and the VR
optimisations as part of N,
the controller, the viewer,
and some of the
tools that you'll
have access to as developers.
Like the discovery
windows where you
can push new experiences
and so on to users
as part of Daydream Home.
But of course, the smartphones,
the operating systems,
the headset, the controller,
it's not what VR is about.
It's about the stuff that
you can do, the experiences.
And we hope you're going
to create many of those.
And from the beginning,
from early on with Daydream,
we've been very focused
on making it really easy
for developers.
And one of the companies that's
been at the forefront of VR
development is Unity.
And John Riccitiello,
their CEO, has
been one of the
earliest supporters
of what we're doing at Google
in VR and with Daydream.
And he gets what
Daydream is about,
and I think he sees
where VR is going.
And I'm delighted to have
him here to say a few words.
So John, please.
JOHN RICCITIELLO:
So thanks, Clay.
It's an incredible
honor to be here.
And I want to start by just
making a simple observation.
Google and Unity are deeply
aligned on our values,
in particular about the
way we see virtual reality,
how we see VR.
Now the mission
of democratization
has been at the core of Unity
Technologies since our founding
about 10 years ago.
Democratization,
what that means is
putting the power
of our technology
in the hands of
developers globally,
whether they can afford or not.
A very big deal.
Now, Google VR under
Clay is about mobile.
Leveraging the power of the
CPU literally in billions
of pockets around the world.
Everyone's included.
That's another type
of democratization,
and it's at this core value that
we're fundamentally aligned.
Now from the beginning,
our orientation
to supporting the
developer has brought us
a fairly sizable audience.
As you can see behind me, 5
and 1/2 million developers.
That's a large number of
people using a game engine,
or game technology.
These developers in
aggregate produce games
that are downloaded 600
to 700 times per second,
1.6 billion times per month.
And if you want to think about
that as an aggregate audience,
it's about 500 million DAUs
of games built on Unity.
So this development
community, all of you,
is a very, very big thing.
If you think about
it, perhaps you'd
that democratization across
five million developers
is very serious scale.
Now Unity, as Clay has
mentioned, from the beginning,
has been making big
investments in VR.
Some of you may have seen
our version of the metaverse,
creating VR from within VR.
That certainly got
a lot of people
lit up on YouTube
and in our community.
And were also very much aware
of Google's roadmap in VR,
and we intend to be and are
there every step of the way.
Now as part of that,
we're announcing
support for Daydream.
Surprise.
We'll be there, we are there.
It'll be native inside of
Unity, very easy to use.
And we're also providing
support for Vulcan, which
we're launching next quarter.
So the core fundamental
technologies that you need
will be right out of the
box, easy to use from Unity.
But beyond that, simple
announcement, we're here,
we're ready, to get on board.
I got two things I want to
talk about briefly, two ideas.
The first of them,
really, is that I
think VR is going to
be driven by mobile.
We envision a world where
literally billions of people
have access to VR.
And the fact that there's
really twice as many people
with mobile devices as
PCs makes that obvious.
It's just math.
So mobile's going to drive
this in the fullness of time,
and again, we're
there to support that.
And the second idea that
I want to get across
is I don't believe that VR
is going to be about games
or simple shopping apps.
I think it's literally going
to extend the human experience.
Imagine a world 10 years from
now, where you blink and you're
standing in the Taj Mahal.
Or you blink and you're
in New York City.
Or you Blink yet
again, and instead
of being in a silver
tube flying 40,000 feet,
you're soaring on the
wing tips of the plane
and experiencing flight like
you've never seen before.
Or you're on stage with
your favorite band.
Not in front like all of
you are, but right there,
involved in a way that
feels intimate and connected
to the people you idolize.
Or blink again,
you're in a classroom
taking a physics class from your
favorite professor at Caltech,
or you're inside a game in a
way you've never seen before.
Or perhaps you're talking
to your best friend,
and your best friend is
thousands of miles away.
But they're sitting next
to you in your couch
in a way that feels intimate,
full, and fully present.
These will all happen.
Imagine, if you
want another one,
think about that old
silly movie, Innerspace,
or Fantastic Voyage.
You'll be in that
capsule traveling
through the bloodstream
from the brain
and quite possibly through to
the end of it in the bowel.
It's all going to be
possible, and maybe you
don't want that last experience.
But think about shopping online.
Except it'll be
social, and you can
try the clothes on
against an avatar
that matches your
body's dimensions.
Again, all a lot closer.
Walking alongside the
surface of the Mars
with a future astronaut.
Except unlike he or she, who's
going to be probably stuck
there for the rest of their
lives, all you have to do
is take off the HMD
and you're home.
So the holodeck will happen.
We've all seen Star Trek,
that level of presence
is going to happen.
You'll be closer to your
nearest and dearest.
My two daughters live in
cities far away from me,
and I'm looking forward
to the opportunity
to connect with them in a
much more close way that makes
me feel like I'm right there.
And I've already experienced
that in some VR chat
development that's
pretty amazing.
And at the core of all this,
is we built the Unity engine
to support 3D development
and quite naturally
to support Daydream.
We've got 5 million
developers, all of you,
ready to jump on board.
And all of you, I hope you're
dreaming about all the ideas
that I laid out and
many, many more.
Dream them, build them,
life will never be the same,
it will be one heck
of a lot better.
And with that, Clay,
you're back on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAY BAVOR: Thank
you so much, John.
As John said, we're just
deeply aligned on this idea
of democratizing access to VR.
Both the creation of it, and
also the consumption of it.
And so it's been a natural
partnership from the beginning.
And I want to thank
John, and I want
to thank all the folks
at Unity who've been so
supportive of what we're doing.
John talked about the
future, and that's
where I want to end as well.
And one of the ways
of figuring out
what's going to
happen in the future
is to look back on the recent
past and recent progress.
So I want to look back less than
a year to last year's Google
I/O, and a couple things
we talked about there.
The first was something
we called Expeditions.
And Expeditions,
if you remember,
is this tool for teachers
that make it possible
for them to take classes
on field trips to anywhere.
From coral reefs to Machu
Picchu, all virtually.
And for the last school
year, Expeditions
has been on the road
throughout the United States
and in countries
around the world.
And in just this
school year, we've
taken over one million
students on expeditions.
[APPLAUSE]
The other thing we
announced last year
was something we called Jump.
Jump is a camera system
and processing software
that works in the cloud that
makes the creation of VR video
seamless at very high quality.
And we built it because we
think the world is awesome,
but we didn't see a great way
of capturing it immersive in VR.
And we partnered
with GoPro to build
what's called the Odyssey.
And actually, we happen
to have one here.
And if you're tuning in from
VR later, great to see you.
Thanks for being here with us.
If everyone could just, like,
wave and say hi to our-- great,
thanks, thanks for being here.
So the Odyssey is rolling
out to some amazing creators.
And the likes of Discovery,
Paramount the New York Times.
And people are saying
really nice things about it.
The quality, how fast it
is, how seamless it is.
But I think the
best summary of it
was we were at the
New York Times,
and one of the New York Times
creative leads, after seeing it
all came together,
just turned to one
of the tech leads of Jump and
said, can I give you a hug?
So we took that hug,
thank you very much.
So Jump, from the beginning,
was built as a platform.
Meaning the software, which
we called the Jump Assembler,
the stuff that does the
magic of turning 16 camera
views into omnidirectional
stereoscopic video,
we built it to be flexible,
to support multiple camera
architectures.
And there are two new ones
we'd like to introduce today.
The first is from Yi Technology.
Yi is a Chinese company with
a strong presence in Asia,
and they're going to be
using their 4k action
cam to build a Jump-ready
camera that will be available
later this year.
We've got a lot of interest
from another area as well,
and that's from Hollywood.
Hollywood is asking us for
a cinema grade Jump camera.
And we're going to build
them one with IMAX.
I'm excited about that.
So IMAX, of course, is known
around the world for incredibly
immersive capture and
audio, and they're
going to be bringing their
decades of experience
in camera design, optics,
sensors, and more, to Jump.
And we're just incredibly
excited about what we're going
to be able to do with them.
So looking ahead, it's
exciting to think about just
where we'll be in the
near future with Daydream.
By the end of this
year, there will
be multiple Daydream ready
phones out on the market,
and I hope your next
phone is one of them.
The first Daydream ready
headsets and controllers
will be rolling out from
the reference design.
And by the way,
it's not just going
to be partners building
from the reference design.
We, Google, are
also going to build
a controller and a headset,
and make it available.
[APPLAUSE]
Beyond that, the technology
just gets better, and better,
and better.
VR is just going to get
better, and better, and better.
And one of the ways that
we see it getting better
is with Project Tango.
Now Tango and Daydream were
part of the same team at Google.
We sit in the same building.
And I'll let you
extrapolate from there,
but we're pretty excited
about what's ahead.
So over the next two days, there
are 17 sessions covering all
of this in a lot more detail.
Everything from how to monetize
and distribute VR apps,
designing with the
controller, everything
you need to build for
daydream and also for Tango.
And there are some great
sessions on all of this.
So we really hope
to see you there.
Thank you so much
for joining us here.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]